sentando las bases para un futuro
intercambio intenso entre eeuu y china
las dos partes concluyeron dos días de
conversaciones en anchorage alaska este
fue el primer encuentro de alto nivel
entre la administración by denny el
gobierno chino las conversaciones fueron
una nueva prueba para las relaciones
cada vez más tensas entre los dos países
que se encuentran enfrentados en varios
asuntos como el comercio los derechos
humanos en tíbet
hong kong la región occidental de
xinjiang así como taiwán y la soberanía
del mar de china meridional además de la
pandemia del coronavirus asuntos que
eeuu no dudó en abordar durante las
discusiones
wisley manabí realmente sabemos y
sabíamos que hay una serie de asuntos en
los que estábamos fundamentalmente
enfrentados incluyendo las acciones de
china en xinjiang con la vista puesta en
concón tíbet y taiwán así como las
acciones que están llevando a cabo en el
ciberespacio y no es una sorpresa que
cuando tocamos estos asuntos de manera
clara y directa obtuvimos una posición
defensiva en wing race dos de sus
por su parte china dijo que el diálogo
era la única manera de resolver las
diferencias y dejaron claro que beijing
no tenía intención de retroceder en
ningún asunto
champagne
las dos partes deberían tratar la
relaciones china-eeuu con el espíritu de
no conflicto la no confrontación el
respeto mutuo y una cooperación en la
que todos ganan
summers ones
y las conversaciones comenzaron con el
anuncio de washington de nuevas
sanciones por la represión china contra
las peticiones de mayor democracia en
hong kong
en respuesta a beijing intensificó su
condena a lo que consideran como una
interferencia estadounidense en los
asuntos internos chinos